getting a new phone is really exciting
and getting money for your old one is
two but before you send those devices
off to resell services like declutter or
gazelle or before you take it to your
mobile carrier to trade in there's a few
things you might want to do first
you want to be sure you're not handing
over a device with your personal data on
it or sending in a phone that's still
linked to your account so today we're
going to go through some of the best
ways to clean up your phone's hardware
and software so you'll be ready to part
ways with it
[Music]
okay so step one the first thing you
want to do is back up your phone's data
to a cloud or to a computer both are
pretty easy to do on iphones and
androids for your apple device go to
icloud settings and turn on icloud
backup
when your phone is connected to wi-fi
plugged in to charge and locked apple
will start adding your data to the cloud
you can also perform a manual backup by
tapping backup now
what's really annoying though is if your
icloud backup requires more than five
gigabytes of data you have to either
decide what content you don't want or
buy more storage
for updated android devices you can use
the backup by google one feature
launched in 2021 it gives you 15 gigs of
storage to back up your device or you
can pay for more if you want
one way you can try to get around
storage limits is to connect your phone
to a computer and back it up that way
either way be sure to backup your
phone's contacts photos videos really
anything that you would regret losing if
it's gone because once it's not saved
you probably won't get it back
it's also really smart to set up
automatic backups on your new device in
case you break it or happen to lose it
so now you're backed up
the next big thing you're going to want
to do is to sign out of all your
accounts you're going to want to go
through each of your apps and manually
sign out of your accounts that way those
services don't list old devices that
you've long since gotten rid of if
you're switching from iphone to android
be sure to sign out of imessages that
way you don't have any issues getting
new messages on your new device
now it's time to sign out of the phone
itself scroll to the bottom of your
apple id menu and tap sign out otherwise
the device will appear stolen and
there's nothing new owners can do with
it
and if you have an android you'll want
to go into your settings and log out of
your google account
[Music]
now you want to clear your data from the
phone and restore it so that all that
remains are whatever settings were
pre-installed by the manufacturer that's
where a factory reset comes in the exact
location of factory reset options varies
from phone to phone updated iphones
should give you a setting to transfer or
reset the phone under your general
settings
and here's what it looks like on an
android phone i had to poke around a
little bit but found it under the
general management settings
once the resets are done your phone
should be in its original state and
we're almost ready to go
[Music]
the final step is something you really
don't want to forget because it's a
little important clean the outside of
your phone making the phone look brand
new might help you get more money if
you're selling it online and it's also
just good hygiene
a good microfiber cloth an alcohol based
cleaner and a q-tip should do the trick
and with that the device you've been
carrying around is ready for its next
phase of life
with a new owner
i'll miss you
if you want to know more about the
latest tech and how it all works be sure
to subscribe to my channel and comment
below to let me know what i should look
into next until next time